Philip Alwar you this morning how's
morale hey Dan doing well are you I'm
doing okay I noticed eight kids
you have six daughters six daughters ami
was gone okay you have like hold it held
to hold your oldest daughter oh this is
just just turn 15
oh yeah okay three girls three girls
were oldest so we got we got three big
girl helpers that's a helps out a lot
oh my god are you prepared for this no
six wedding I love I'm telling you I
don't know 15 15 is when it really hit
me as I go my goodness is going to go to
the ninth grade I don't know if I update
well what's tougher you know facing like
the Raiders defense or you know having
to deal with six daughters whether they
both present different challenges
preserve us years nobody talks about
families great blessing I should later
healthy and happy and it's been a good
break but as it always does my wife
always tells me she's like huh until the
training camps almost here the ornaments
now Donna Claus did you ask your college
coach if it was okay to get married well
I did i Chuck a motto I was I was a I
was 18 years old I just turned 19 you
know I just didn't know how it worked
you know you're supposed to resource me
the door for two years I was like gosh I
guess I better I guess if I ask folks oh
no uh yeah he was on the list along with
my wife's my father-in-law now and and
in college jokes they were both on the
list of I've had to make sure ask them
what if he said no yeah I think it was
one of those you know is one of those we
already already think you know the
answer so I went prepared for her know
so I don't know what would happen but
why are you getting married at 18
well there was lots of there's lots of
factors I wanted one I just and and then
both of us were trying to remain
in taste until we are married and and
suited with the time of the time was
right and we've known each other since
she's eighth grade so yeah soon as the
one she is 15 says now so and eight
children so Thursday's very expensive
who's your favorite player and team
growing up you know I grew up in North
Alabama so until it tightens move there
I mean a falcon so pro pro football for
me I wanted as brittle fans I was
college football being Catholic I was a
Notre Dame plan and then I pull curtains
you know invested so it wasn't a huge
Auburn Alabama fan witches which is a
little bit crazy being a state usually
you're one of the other pretty dark but
pro football laws I was a fan of
quarterbacks I had Marino and painting
and phones and eight men and la mine
corner all those guys were the posters
on my wall so I was more about NFL
quarterback fan and then a college
football for Notre Dame recruit Notre
Dame did not recruit me they I went to
camp up there just because I want to see
it and ready recruiter Marion's doing
that phase of very little option to do
and so it shows actually fit well it
shows a great turbulence who they have
like Tony rice bank then Josh's or
Jackson there's a Jackson to right and
then Jarius Jackson I think
Jairus Jackson and then MNR here I said
it was ruining a band yeah we went to
camp up there
leave my mom and brother and sister
drove up to South Bend and to Michigan
actually those are always schools up
north and I went to a camp and neither
one no one no one were real interested
did you hold it against those schools
no no but you always want no but I
always want to play Notre Dame and
finally got the chance to play in the
Gator Bowl there buddy here we played
them the year that they won ten games we
won 11 games we played them in the Gator
boys excellent being pretty good so that
was one of the college highlights for me
Philip Rivers Chargers quarterback do
your kids do they are you their favorite
player yeah I think I can accomplish
comfortably say that they have other
guys they'd like oh yeah and they really
start to get into it certainly the girls
know who schools 15 12 and 11
they're into it but my older son is not
he's the most into it he knows he can
they can tell you every quarterback and
player and this and that
80 bucks to watch practice room with me
and unless Caltech is all all the way
that but ya know I'm still hanging on
the first place is their favorite player
okay what if your son said I'd like to
have a derrick karr Jersey dad well I
don't think that's gonna I don't think
I'm gonna be faced with that question
when I'm being right then I guess it's
something I'd like to be done playin
though and then I think you might could
handle it but so far so far there's just
17 jerseys in the house have you thought
about how long you want to play I uh I
don't have a year on it or like how it
likes plate this Minho motor plates on
the certain days but it done I feel like
I got a handful left I mean I got three
years on this Curt contract and I'd like
to help last ax I can help Lodge if I'm
playing well enough they still want me
to stick around I think there's a lot of
factors but I still love it I still love
the preparation part of it I love the
Monday through Saturday almost as much
as you Sunday in a different way I love
to get up and going and trying to figure
out a defense and be a teammate and
being a locker room and all those things
so I think when that goes along with if
you when you play goes obviously doesn't
know the first thing you know it'll end
it for you but I think in that passion
for what they go in there and get after
it and prepare and all those things I
think that's when you that's when you
know maybe it's the self the self job of
it is estate but but that's all still
right there as excited as ever for this
year and but also had a play better and
play play well okay
again Ansel and
how different is your personality on the
field as opposed to off the field uh I
mean I don't know that it's different I
think it comes out of different ways I
mean I the same passion there I like to
play interesting pounces have being a
dad being a husband not it's not that it
is animated and as you see on the field
but it's genuine and is real I mean I'm
energetic and I'd love for the game I'd
love for people love for my family so I
think I think really this is the way and
what you ever lean on and it's expressed
differently but I'm genuinely a
passionate enthusiastic person and I
think you just smelled early microfilm
ready to cross in a negative way and I'd
like to thank ladies notes so what's
known in overtime that it says yes maybe
you're just like a big kid out there
that just loves the blade and the
somewhat banter and talking that he had
interaction that he has with other teams
probably would have it the back yard
with his mother and his buddies and
that's exactly right and that's all it
is so but in a lot of ways very basic
but dominating not a shot not as
animated and and excited all fulfilled
but still someone well I have a guy who
is usually here my Booker Todd Fritz
he's a die-hard Bronco fan and for
summary he hate holiday he hates you he
doesn't know you but he just hates
seeing Philip Rivers face the Broncos
yeah and of all days he called in sick
today
yeah had a chance to yeah we've had a
chance to solve everything he can he
called in he called in sick we could we
could have got it all straightened out
is there a message for Fritzi that you
would like to deliver Philip no I figure
I think he falls in the phone mode the
most marvelous man I don't think I'm too
loved indifferent there was a stretch
there there was a stretch there where we
had a lot except in Denver and it gets
those Broncos so I think that plays
reportedly they got the best of us now
the past several years we met on top but
but once or twice and so it's
understandable but it's funny though
because it's my favorite place to play I
love going on the stadiums awesome the
setting with the mountains and then
atmosphere the fans the fans roll and
then you playing against what's going on
of the better teams over the last six
years so they've always been one of our
favorite places to go tougher fan base
to deal with the Raiders or the Broncos
or somebody else yeah well I I think he
just is in Division Canadian some of
this cause I think your point the most
but but all three Kansas City then your
local angry that the atmospheres are
different and all all percents out is
especially not greater Scout things turn
about it there's a little spam there
well maybe it wasn't what you know you
always heard about and then now it's
back to that and it's awesome and then
in Kansas City does it still as loud as
in my awesome three time points years
ago and three teams are really good I
think our division is is arguably one of
the best in the in football right now
and I think it will be again this year
I got you making the playoffs this year
all right yeah yeah you you pretty said
you had no chance but I said the
Chargers are winning at least ten games
and you're making the playoffs this year
so just letting you know I'm on the
bandwagon early so it's not one of those
when you guys do well and you guys say
well nobody thought we wouldn't be here
I'm going to be there for you okay
also you can you imagine can you imagine
can you imagine the home playoff game or
StubHub I like it something with it I
like it and I'm going to guess you'll
sell it out to it what it did whether
twenty twenty-five thousand seeds so I
will fill that up at hurt explain this
groove ring these are wedding rings that
that yeah explain this yes silicon it's
a silicon ring your metal wedding really
is you want to wear on a ton of Edessa
okay also must wait to take it out to
climate you know this like where no
matter what all the time never have to
take it off and it's up it's a really
it's comfortable its breathable so it
doesn't sweat like some of the other
silicon rings they sweat a lot all over
the place this once you hardly know you
have on it and I think what's what's
even awesome grooving it's a lifetime
guarantee so if you lose in it for some
crazy reason it breaks but Johnny I
can't imagine it would they'll send you
know the right away so it's a you know
so many all the across fed and all the
things so many different things that
come in you know in the last 10 years
and so in so many people acted and what
know where they're winning that all the
time but they can't with those with a
regular one so yeah it's awesome
is there a website that people can learn
more about this yeah I ask you this
typing groove rain groove life it'll be
the first thing up and it's it's all
there and shooters there's different
colors there's different styles you
could be sleek and look like your
regular band or powder blue and charger
no I like that
colors I got everything can you do maybe
maybe you could send one to fritz in you
guys can have a friendship ring and then
maybe you know we could bring you two
closer together well maybe I can give
him one designs and I didn't want and
maybe have a sort of paint on it you
know and hey it's good to have you on
anymore kids on the horizon not as of
now but ranks will do a quick check
though do a quick inventory here just
just to make sure there's not a ninth
one that may have happened during the
interview or else we're all square we're
all good all eight are counted for
awesome Philip great to have you on the
program thanks for being a good sport
all right thanks yeah that's a Phillip
Rivers groove ring I think we get a
friendship ring there for Fritzi
that might bring those two closer
together the Dan Patrick show weekday
mornings on audience